let's start with what's quite a striking
chart just showing you economic activity
in the manufacturing sector in China and
here you have the biggest plunge that
we've seen in this index it's a measure
of just how much activity is going on in
the manufacturing sector anything about
the lies expansion anything below is
contraction just look at how much it
plunge even more as a result of covin 19
in the shut downs we've seen in China
than at any point going back to the
financial crisis worse in fact than many
months of the financial crisis and the
upshot of this is that there have been
some very visible impacts on China the
shutdown of factories actually if you
look at these pictures showing you
pollution around China so there you have
Wuhan and they've got Hong Kong and you
can see pollution around China in
January and just look at what happened
in February a complete disappearance of
pollution around these areas and
economists are putting that down to the
shut down in many factories around China
so good in terms of air pollution but in
terms of economic activity well there's
the concern and the OECD which is a big
organization which looks as these things
is talking about enormous falls in
Chinese GDP as a result of these
shutdowns that's the concern if you're
doing containment whatever the virulence
of the disease you're shutting down
economic activity and in China they say
there's going to be potentially 1.4
percent fall in GDP there compared with
what they were previously expecting
similar in America and the clear the
distinction here is between what they
think is likely that's actually there
what best their best case scenario and
what they think could happen if the
disease isn't contained elsewhere look
at North America small projection if
things stay contained if they don't
you've got a big fall a very big fall
indeed and over here in Europe and
obviously this concludes the UK as well
the expectation is only a small fall in
GDP but if the disease is not contained
by the way this is their best case
scenario relatively small if the disease
is not contained then essentially you've
got recessions all across Europe
including in the UK and that's something
that's going to concern really seen that
the Chancellor with his budget just
coming up worth just finishing on this
this shows you this is every single week
in changes in the footsie 100 it's the
index of shares in London in the UK and
it goes back to 1984 this shows you
every single week and just look at the
biggest fools that we've seen over this
period 1987 Black Monday an enormous for
their financial crisis there as well
there's lines going down there but look
at this 2020 coronavirus Koch covert 19
that is the third biggest weekly fall
that we've seen since this index was
created so an extraordinary fall the
good news is the footsie has recovered
today so we have seen it get back some
of that ground but not really all that
much so big concerns there about markets
and indeed the global economy